I'll be in Bangkok at some points my
opponents buzzer King okay i'll bezerk
back because he's 1440 let's play e4
let's stick with e4 for a little bit
ah the Petroff
let's just play some mainline I told
myself before this tournament started
that I'm gonna try and play more like
classical chess it's more positional in
nature okay so we'll go back I'll admit
I really don't know too much theory here
for a students who play against the
Petrova I usually recommend Knight c3 it
leads just an easy position to play
usually a leading tops it's like
castling queenie 7 that's a very good
sign that he doesn't know this
this variation queenie sevens just a
positional mistake because it blocks the
bishop and slows down development and
aligns the king and the queen on the
open file so rookie ones coming next and
good things are about to happen
hopefully
so Queen d7 okay admitting his his error
I think I'm gonna play rookie one anyway
she rookie one Bishop e7 thinking I
could play Queen d4 but then he just
Casas the goal is to prevent black from
casting somehow so rook e1 Bishop e7
Queen d5 Queen d5 looks interesting in
c6 I have an idea rook e1 Bishop e7
Knight g5 takes takes 96
and maybe like queen h5 let's play
rookie one first
I'm trying some maxima is like the
temporary advantage the fact I'm
developed a bit more and castled have
the e-file looking at Bishop e7 Bishop
g5 and then castling and then I take and
he takes back I don't think there's any
useful discoveries so Knight g5 looks
more appealing
Quincy for a Quincy thoughts
I mean they g5 might just be hopeful to
but it makes some sense I'm just trying
to initiate the trade of Bishops and get
the battery on the file
keone suggesting moves could be tricky
Ricky warned the ship g5 to provoke f6
yeah I want an efficiency if I worked I
would go for it yeah castling I think
would have been enough so I'm getting
the battery and now the king is tied
down to the fame the bishop expecting
knight c6 no the king is not tied down
so I was looking at Queen h5 earlier I
think I'll go for
focusing on a new targets if g6 and
maybe queen h6
and then the king is tied down to f7 so
castling queenside shouldn't work I am
spending a lot of energy against this
much lower rated player but that's life
just takes energy
I still have ideas of 96 here never mind
so Queen h6 or Queen f3 Queen f3
castling let's play Queen h6 it's
important to prevent castling and now I
just take there's Bishop f8 Oh Bishop f8
there's a nice move queen h3 pinning the
Queen and guaranteeing winning the
exchange so that rooks are fourths it's
a miracle
oh he plays Bishop I fade so I play this
nice thing is I rooks aren't connected
so he doesn't have like rookie Yeates if
the bishop was somehow on g7 rook e8
would save them I'm accepting double
each pawns I'll win the when one of the
rooks for a knight I'll have an extra
pawn to safe one f7 that's nice
and I'll get the bonus beserk points if
I win this
Bishop e7 I don't know I could take
either rook or I could take the Queen oh
let's take the Queen first he takes with
rook I win this flat-out takes with King
then I take here and now I'll play
quicker now we're gonna see why your
dominance over minor pieces especially
in the endgame but I do have to save the
bishop
let's move towards the center the plan
is rook d1z for c5 open up more files
restrict the night sometimes when you're
up material a decent strategy is just to
kill your opponent's counterplay
it's ensure that they have nothing and
go for it simplifications defend the
pawn and restricting the Knights this
structure is usually very good against a
knight on c6 so he's maneuvering let's
double up
expecting night of 4mm rookie three
would get Forks I play a three let's
play a three a 396 let's just do this
now rookie 7 is a massive threats which
is hard to stop now I think the goal is
to double up rooks on the seventh rank
and just start eating pawns I just want
to play rook g7 oh I forgot about that
but that pawn doesn't matter
rook g7 I could win the a pawn
should I've seen a to was hanging though
okay let's just double up Brooks is
calculating h6 Ricky e7 rook c8 Beth all
when they each paw and try and just went
on the kingside
I should pay attention to my back rank
for the time being it's safe nights are
not very good at back rank meeting so
the goal is just so when these pawns and
then push he's defending hmm so let's
try harder
Oh see five
oh let's put the work back
interesting
okay now I'm winning more stuff King b6
is a better try opening lots more stuff
let's just not mess around and promotes
okay decently hard-fought game
been a while since I've had to meet like
this at least in a slower game
why not just force the rupture in clay
enforce our trade earlier maybe I could
have with rookie AIDS yeah rook e8 also
possible
I thought the combination of rooks was
more fun to play with but sometimes
positioned like this there's multiple
ways to win back to tournaments so I got
three tournament points for winning that
game 170th place not sure if that game
was YouTube worthy maybe it is we'll see